[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a drama fantasy film
called ricky
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins with a tired mother of
two named katie contemplating putting
her baby ricky up for adoption katie
works a low-wage job at a cosmetics
factory and lives in welfare housing in
eastern paris she says she hasn't been
able to look after ricky and her
daughter lily by herself after her
partner left her the social worker
reminds her that abandoning a child is a
big decision and she should spend more
time making sure that she is taking the
right step for the meantime the social
worker offers to see if domestic help
can be arranged for katie to help her
look after the baby katie is also
advised to file a police report that her
baby's father has abandoned her the
movie then flashes back to the past
before baby ricky was born after waking
up lily opens the curtains and wakes up
her perennially tired mother lily then
heads to the kitchen and begins
preparing breakfast for herself and her
mother the mother daughter then take a
shower and have breakfast together
before leaving for lily's school in
katie's scooter katie promises to pick
her up later before kissing her goodbye
and heads to work at the factory katie
locks eyes with a man named paco sanchez
paco walks up to her during a cigarette
break and introduces himself katie lends
him a cigarette and paco reveals that he
recently started working at the factory
one thing leads to another and the two
end up hooking up in the washroom as a
result katie takes time finishing her
daily work quota and gets in trouble
with her boss who scolds her for being
lazy katie also arrives late to pick up
lily from school moreover she forgets to
bring lily's helmet and she is forced to
give lily her own helmet on their ride
back home the next day paco meets katie
outside the factory katie expresses her
embarrassment over the fact that they
hooked up right after first meeting
saying it is not usually her style
paco agrees with her saying he doesn't
hook up on first dates either
sure you don't paco after making some
more small talk paco asks her out on a
date katie who has been longing for
company couldn't be more excited and she
accepts the date much to lily's dismay
who wanted to play dress-up with her
mother at the date paco asks katie about
lily's father and she reveals that he
lives in southern france lily's father
wanted katie to abort her so he wants
nothing to do with katie and their
daughter meanwhile paco reveals that he
was briefly married in spain when he was
young after the date katie takes him
back home and the two make love again
poor lily has a hard time falling asleep
due to the sound of katie and paco's
lovemaking the next day lily wakes up to
katie and paco having breakfast together
katie tries to introduce her daughter to
her date but the little girl isn't
interested and she runs back to her room
to spend more time with paco katie also
signs lily up for the school bus service
and paco eventually moves into katie's
home a year passes by and katie becomes
pregnant with paco's child one day paco
gets a call at work from the hospital
and learns that katie has unexpectedly
gone into labor he rushes to be by
katie's side with lily after katie gives
birth to a healthy baby boy paco asks
lily for suggestions for the baby's name
and lily names the baby ricky
paco turns lily's room into a nursery
much to her dismay and she begins to
feel sidelined by her mother who spends
most of her time with the new baby lily
also doesn't like the fact that katie
keeps insisting that lily call paco dad
katie's spending most of her time
looking after the baby also begins to
take a toll on her relationship with
paco and one day lily catches paco
cozying up to another woman outside
their apartment building however lily
decides to keep it to herself paco later
returns home late saying he was out with
his friends paco's changed attitude
worries katie and the two get into an
argument however the two make up before
going to bed promising to be there for
each other more soon katie starts going
to work again and paco is left to look
after the baby during the day one day
when katie returns home she notices a
strange bruise on baby ricky's back she
asks paco about it but he denies knowing
anything about it paco insists that it's
nothing but over the course of the next
few days the baby grows another bruise
on his back the poor baby also keeps
crying all the time one day katie
confronts paco about the twin bruises
paco again denies knowing anything about
it but katie accuses him of beating
ricky this upsets paco and he breaks up
with her before leaving seeing paco
storm out in anger lily realizes that he
has left for good and the little girl
embraces her mother to comfort her with
paco out of the picture lily becomes
ricky's prime babysitter one day katie
returns home to find ricky missing from
his cradle where the baby has left
behind a strange gooey mark lily and
katie frantically look for the baby lo
and behold they locate the baby on top
of the closet when they bring the baby
down to their astonishment they notice
two wings growing from ricky's shoulder
blades it seems ricky can move his wings
which help him levitate katie gives the
baby a bath and washes the blood off of
his little wings she decides to keep
ricky caged in his cradle to keep him
from hurting himself and she also warns
lily against saying anything about ricky
in her school fearing it would only
attract unnecessary attention towards
the baby at times katie feels the urge
to call paco but she can't ever bring
herself to do it since developing the
wings ricky sleeps well and becomes
cheerful in one week ricky's wings grow
17 centimeters long and katie designs a
custom dress for the baby as time passes
by ricky develops feathers on the wings
one day paco randomly shows up at lily's
school and asks her about katie and
ricky he also offers to take her home
but she declines the offer and gets on
her bus as ricky grows bigger katie buys
a helmet and knee pads for him so that
he can fly without hurting himself
lily tries to tell katie about paco but
katie interrupts her saying since ricky
started sleeping well she has forgotten
about paco things finally seem to be
going good for katie and her family she
wins a 2 000 euro lottery and with the
winnings they go christmas shopping
unfortunately when lily and katie are
distracted ricky manages to remove his
jacket and starts flying horrifying the
shoppers katie and lily run after the
baby to stop him from hurting himself
the authorities soon catch wind of the
strange baby and they shut down the
entire store an entire army of police
scramble to catch the baby but without
success eventually on katie's advice
they turn out the lights and baby ricky
is finally caught katie is forced to
take ricky to a hospital where doctors
examine the baby the head doctor bernard
asks for katie's permission to keep the
baby in the hospital for further tests
he also says that ricky needs a spacious
environment to properly evolve however
katie declines the offer and when she
proceeds to take her baby home she is
mobbed by people and the media desperate
to catch a glimpse of the baby several
days pass by but the media continues to
camp outside katie's apartment complex
the flying baby has become an
international sensation one night ricky
wouldn't stop crying so lily lets him
fly in his room unbeknownst to katie who
is taking a shower suddenly the doorbell
rings and it is revealed to be paco lily
calls out for her mother who asks lily
to leave her alone with paco katie and
paco apologize to each other and quickly
rekindle their relationship much to
lily's dismay lily expresses her concern
to her half-brother who has flown over
to the top of the closet yet again she
is upset because she feels that now that
paco is back again katie will spend most
of her time with him and ricky meanwhile
paco reveals that all this time he
worked in a restaurant in paris when
katie asks if he had any affairs he
tells her that he hooked up with one or
two women but it wasn't anything serious
we were on a break paco says later paco
meets his son baby ricky doesn't
recognize his father and tries to fly
away when paco attempts to hold him
worried about ricky hurting himself
katie calls him towards herself but
paco's presence scares the baby and he
refuses to come down they eventually
manage to bring the baby down and paco
points out that the room is too
dangerous for ricky to grow up in but
katie tells him to shut up because she
doesn't want to be separated from her
son they learn that baby ricky has hurt
himself from all the flying and they
immediately call the doctor dr bernard
treats ricky's wounds and reiterates
paco's point he says that the apartment
is not safe for ricky to grow up in dr
bernard also suggests a surgical
procedure to remove ricky's wings which
he calls safe but painful however katie
refuses to put her baby through the
surgery later that night lily has the
urge to cut ricky's wings off with a
pair of scissors but before she goes
through with it paco arrives outside the
room to kiss his son goodnight prompting
lily to run back to her bed the next day
over breakfast paco suggests allowing
the media to make a documentary on recce
in exchange for money he says this would
give the family proper monetary
resources required to look after ricky
this makes katie upset and she accuses
paco of returning back to their life so
he could make a buck off of ricky
however paco insists that he only
returned to look after his family and
reminds katie how she previously accused
him of beating ricky asking her to trust
him this time after a lot of convincing
katie gives him the permission to film
ricky the next day on paco's request dr
bernard calls the press in front of
katie's apartment complex for ricky's
media debut katie and paco present
themselves as a happy married family
even though they aren't married they
also put a rope on ricky to keep him
from flying away to demonstrate ricky's
ability they let go of him as katie
holds the rope the baby begins to fly
like a bird much to everyone's
astonishment katie is also excited to
see her baby fly so high for the first
time and as a result she gets lost in
the moment and accidentally lets go of
the rope ricky flies away prompting
katie and the others to chase after the
baby passing through the lake ricky
flies into the woods after waiting for a
while the media loses interest in ricky
and leaves but katie refuses to move
from the spot dr bernard later joins
paco by the lake and suggests that ricky
must have been shot by a hunter or is
starving to death somewhere upset paco
blames himself and laments that katie
will never forgive him for this for the
next few days katie and others spend
their time distributing missing posters
for ricky around the market but it's all
in vain
several weeks pass by and others move on
with their lives but katie still longs
for her son one day she leaves her home
for yet another walk by the lake it
turns out the despondent katie has
decided to end her life however as she
proceeds to drown herself she hears
ricky's voice and his flapping wings as
he returns overjoyed katie runs towards
her baby who has grown up considerably
the baby looks happy and katie
apologizes to him saying that she let go
of him because he looked so happy in the
air the baby then flies away and katie
realizes that ricky's happiness is in
the air she returns home and lovingly
embraces her family after a long while
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching